we have seen a sequence like three five
seven nine and so on in the sequence
three is the first term to define the
nth term in a simpler way we just call
the first term as a how do we define the
second term then the common difference
as we can see is two if we call the
common difference as D the second term
can be written as a plus D what can the
third term be written as that's easy we
write it as a plus 2d first term plus
twice the common difference so based on
this logic how can we write the nth term
we can write it as a plus n minus 1
times D why n minus 1 observe the
pattern third term 2d second term 1d so
this is the formula we had seen earlier
first term plus n minus 1 times D it's
just that we have written the first term
as a now that we have seen individual
terms in a sequence we can get to the
sum of their terms how do we find the
sum of all the terms in a sequence think
of it in terms of average the average of
n terms will be the sum of terms over n
so the sum of terms will be n times the
average understanding the average is the
best part of it all sequences are evenly
spaced numbers for evenly spaced numbers
the average is the sum of first term and
the last term over 2 that's it we get
the sum of terms if we know the number
of terms the first term and the last
term the sum of terms in a sequence is
called series we will understand more
about it in our future sessions
let's take the 2 outside and write n by
2 the first term is a and this is the
last term so first term plus the last
term is equal to 2 a plus n minus 1
times D this is the formula to
find the sum of terms in a sequence but
wait this is only an arithmetic sequence
yes this is an arithmetic sequence as
the difference between two consecutive
terms is constant but wait what are the
other types of sequences then to look at
more types we go through the next
sequence 3 9 27 81 and so on pause the
video and think about whether this is a
sequence or not okay some of you would
have assumed that as the difference
between two consecutive terms is not
constant this is probably not a sequence
don't forget the definition of a
sequence it is simply a set of numbers
which have some pattern and the pattern
can be anything did you spot a pattern
here look at the ratio of two
consecutive terms the ratio 9 over 3 is
equal to 3 and the ratio of 27 to 9 is
also 3 just like the common difference
in arithmetic we have a common ratio
here we can call it our each term is
multiplied by 3 to get the next term
this is called a geometric sequence of
progression let's assume the first term
of the sequence as a what will be the
second term then it will be 8 times the
common ratio R and the third term it
will be 8 times R squared and what will
be the nth term of a geometric
progression look at the pattern second
term R raised to one third term R raised
to two so the nth term will be eight
times R raised to n minus one and what
will be the sum of the terms in a
geometric sequence this is just a
formula you need to know 8 times 1 minus
R raised to n over 1 minus R the proof
of this is
easy and it is good to know but you
don't really need to know it for your
exams so the four things you should know
for the exams end term and some of terms
for an arithmetic sequence and the nth
term and sum of terms for a geometric
sequence